as has happened before in other  elections including with donald trump's  in 2020  we didn't have the results around 11 p.m  or midnight eastern on election day and  donald trump posted to troth central  quote  dr oz should declare victory it makes it  much harder for them to cheat with the  ballots that they quote just happen to  find end trump's quote and end full  quote  that's an authoritarian nightmare and  that is exactly you know when we go back  to trump coming out at 2am on election  day in november of 2020 and saying we  won when he very clearly hadn't won it  wasn't clear he lost but it was very  clear he hadn't yet won  he's admitting what the game is here you  say you won you just take credit for it  and it makes it harder than and it  poisons the well where people say i  don't know i mean he claimed victory he  must have won